FOR
THE CANES BACK INTO THE ARIZONA
ZONE.
KEEPING THE HANG ON.
>> Tripp: SVECHNIKOV HAS A
HISTORY OF PLAYING WITH JORDAN
PLAY RECENTLY, THURSDAY NIGHT
IN TAMPA, FRIDAY IN WASHINGTON,
THEIR WORK ETETPOINT,
HAMMERED THIS IS EVERYONE, AND
THEN JARVIS IS TAKEN DOWN OUT S
JARVIS HAMMERS ONE BUT IT
EIGHT SCORING OPPORTUNITIES,
ICING AGAINST THE CANES, LET'S
GET A LOOK AT SETH JARVIS.
>> M
THE CANES TRYING
DECENT TRAFFIC.
>> Mike: 6'3", 224, STANDS THE
AVIN WILL
RIP ONE RIGHT ON,  AND HE DID,
GOALTENDING.
>> Mike: TWO MINUTES 56 TO
WORK BY KOTKANIEMI TO KEEP
WITH THE STEP ON THE POWER PLAY
STANLEY CUP CHAMPIONSHIP TEAEAP
IT TO BED ON THE POWER PLAY. IS
PLAY.  , THE CANES WILL MAKE TH
CHANGE.
>> Tripp: NECAS HAS BEEN
NOTABLE IN THIS SAFE.
KRAUSE CREATED THAT OPPORTUNITY
ON THE TURNOVERS. THERE
'S A TIP YOUR CAP
MOMENT TO GOFIRST GAME TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE IT WITH YOUR
FAMILY, IS ALWAYS HIGH
>> Tripp: GOOD LOOK HERE , HIM
AND THE PUCK WILL SLIDE BACK TO
HURRICANES AND.
SHOT DOESN'T BITE HIS WAY
THROUGH FOR ANDERSON, HE'S ON W
PUCK OUT WITH THHALLOWEEN REWAR
SETS PLAY OFF OF CAPTAINED BY S
HECKUVA TONE.
ON ONE KNEE.MALKA.
THE MELCO MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN A
PIECE, SETH JARVIS, THE ROOKIE
SATELLITE DOWN TO
ON THE ICE, SO WITH ALL OF HIS
WEAPONS, STARTS THE SE
BACK DOWN LOW, CHYCHRUN LETS IT
GO FOR CASTLE.